[Music]
anyway which one am I looking at this
one all right hi guys how's it going
welcome to the balloon animal challenge
I hope this is a delightful close-up
help us oh so close
give me nice and close it's a good close
stop
welcome to the balloon anyway welcome to
the balloon animal challenge where meet
Dana some wing is here are gonna be
doing these balloons is it zoomed in or
not hello hi welcome to this camera now
we have air pumps we got balloons I
sucked on it yeah right right so we're
gonna take our sacs of balloons and
we're gonna get suggestions and we're
gonna have one minute to make balloon
animals that is what we discussed one
minute oh it creates a sense of crisis
and urgency if we only have one minute
so we get one starter balloon but then
every other balloon we have one minute
and Kathmandu people can are we ready to
get started yeah well we're starting
with the starter balloons yeah but what
I might need more you never know you're
not gonna win on creativity if you're
only using one balloon
right here right ready start the clock
as soon as she says it
[Music]
pretty smell like pretty snail this is
at Winston there there there's snails
out of their shell making wolf yeah that
smells meat that's a smell nice snap oh
you just I don't even want to debate
mine but believe it up to our impartial
judges why is it can't help but I
explained yours yeah explain it okay
mine is a snail that's overgrown Excel
isn't starting to leave its shell to get
a new shell because the shell is too
small and as you can see it's got the
curls of a normal trumpet pretty good
it's pretty good pretty good mine is a
UC Bearcats snail bats ready for the
game and he is geared up and ready to go
so he's like oh yeah you see yeah no
that's my stuff oh my snail is two
snails that came out of their shells to
come together that's what I said
excuse me but that was my vision no it
was not it was my vision see cirno's
yours and me
my snails smile Michael - snails
we're two snails mating and you can see
how that it's like Eagles falling from
the sky tangling together
so what snails do when they make deals
so much tangled the other one yeah
actually the sky yeah spiral down to the
combination before they hit the ground
yeah yeah but the last thing this looks
like a death dance man that is that is a
drink
so who wins according to the impartial
judges
[Music]
drove off
oh you're right there okay explain yours
you gotta make it work mine is a
butterfly whose wing got grabbed and
can't fly anymore that's so sad my heart
bleeds for that mine is just a normal
butterfly you can see the prodigious
wings you can see its little legs coming
through here you can see the proboscis
[Music]
thorax here you've got the anthrax and
the thorax here
donata me let's probe us kids Dora
spore eggs got it big sentence alright
so pretty
the so mine was a butterfly that was
flapping flapping through a garden his
dog came in tore it in half and this is
all that's left
okay impartial judges who were
[Music]
hurry up be free butterfly what
alright the next annum go ahead
[Music]
mine's the one-year floppy one-eared
sprung bunny it gotten up a fight with
the dog which is why the other years too
floppy and and it's a market bunny so
mind you're like oh what is this
abstract shape wait bunny ear ear face
body to little ennobling spare this is
the proboscis or or you can it's like
modern art you can interpret it many
ways it's a bunny looking forward or
funny-looking to the side in these
videos it's a bunny with tilted head
disease it's about the donkey's head to
see that's a real thing is there really
yeah for bunnies if they good if their
head starts tilting they can't stop in
Linda
then they die they die they're dead
they're gone dead bunnies all of them
all bunnies in the world dead except for
mine I went with a simpler approach this
is ahead in some ears good old-fashioned
ears buddy how dare you easily okay tied
up yeah
[Music]
wait is that time those damn snail stole
my idea I'm looking at you the entire
time go ahead go ahead you even light
years ago even yeah anything can you let
your zero let's go
if only use go is a Portuguese Man O War
you can tell by the smaller top and the
longer tentacle I can see that I can see
that mine is the star jelly fresh from
the movie Finding Nemo it's top was
bounced upon by Dory herself but by
Ellen DeGeneres anyway you can see the
main body and then the danglies it's a
friend I see a cow whale it doesn't
matter what you see it's matter what it
is and it is a jellyfish it is the start
another time it was me yeah explain your
bullsh I really know you're trying to do
mine no worse execution oh I just didn't
blow it up enough so I couldn't see it
Francis yeah you tried the key word is
you tried it yet fail
there you go that's a jellyfish the mark
Markel winner yeah nice argument though
I could definitely see the Man O'War
afterwards I was gonna tie this here oh
that would look great that would it
looks real good okay all right so that
was a speed round the score stands him
one me to him one we're gonna bump it up
into double or nothing this is double
round we double the time we double the
points sound fair
sound fair you guys have a chance to
catch up I have a chance to win
easy-peasy
got it good okay cool
[Music]
let's try met
well you can't keep one yeah yeah yep
time right
mine's a mighty baby blue whale it's
three-dimensional kinda mine's also
three dimensional but better I have a
mama whale cute little mom whether you
have enough fins on the side of those
you get the full shape of the girth of
the mama and then a little baby swimming
alongside big whale see you got to be
valued you the feedback flipper that's
in the water you've got the big fins the
long long body going through the ocean
you can see it now so that's my whale
mine mine was a sperm whale mine who
gets second place though we'll give them
one point I had such sighs he did argue
for it more you kind of was lackluster
on your presentation I can't okay
so this next one will be worth three but
second place will be worth two that we
Ethan could win Tyler could tie it cuz
if Tyler gets that and he gets second
place it's all tied up make sense yep so
first place three points next place two
points if I get this i cinch the win if
I don't I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz I made
up the rules so that I would fail Mingo
ah [ __ ] so much
[Music]
trying to get off my job
so mine is a fancy flamingo its head is
up ready just facing the sky being a
full-on diva you can see this is its
beak it's got two weeks this birds have
wings and it's got two legs but their
inner flopping so do you know how fling
them you know usually stance and like
crosses its legs and Sansome one leg
it's it's full dancing cable okay mine
is a proper all pink flamingo and I
think I'm the only one that has it
standing on one leg like it should be
it's got to [ __ ] me like you can tell
there's a second leg because of the knee
there the knee joint it's resting on the
other one this is the body these are the
glorious wings and this is the face this
one in particular is in mating season
and it's beak has inflated looser become
more prominent and more attractive to
the males so as you can see - all right
well this we're great and everything
like that - doesn't even pink does it
have to be pink no I don't think so
lately an orange flamingo well first of
all it's orange blue
second of all we didn't have to make
accurate colors there's just an artistic
choice and I'm sure the choice is not
well that's my opinion it's these are
the long legs the long body the Flamingo
has a naturally very long leg
here's the body here here's the neck
long legs long body long wings long neck
has long legs big neck like so we've
gotta leave a flamingo we've got the
correct flamingos and we've got the best
flamingos Tyler
second please yeah okay oh I'll bet half
my point on that all of my points that
gives you enough here well it's double
or nothing no it's fine
oh my me yeah you would get four but
yeah going all-in
okay wait all right so you're betting
how many I have how many you have she is
saying I have three to win four yeah
I'll bet it all
I bet at all I'm gonna bet it all then
I'm not gonna bet anything [ __ ] your
last animal is a cockroach Oh
[Music]
good
see mine it's a very demanding cockroach
has two features that are very
distinguishing besides the color the
antennae being overly exact which are
also used as the pincers and it also has
the wing its tail to balance it out now
on a hissing cockroach you don't
necessarily see the legs cuz they are
underneath so you have the full
three-dimensional concept the coloration
and full design um when I think of
cockroach I think of the prominent and
10i and the huge dick that's my main
feature about cockroaches but it's often
confused this is not the Pinay these are
the testes this is the p9 and also this
so you have the earthen color of the
cockroach and it's disgusting nature but
in this you know in a way very cute so
you see it skittering along the ground
and you'll take note that it's it's
actually quite friendly and and you
could learn a lot from its survival
capabilities because no matter what
hardship it gets thrown at it it will
always always come through the end ok
you're describing not your balloon your
vagina you describe it quite well
could you point out the proboscis for oh
of course
right this is the proboscis cool things
you're often this is the ants with mine
you know when I think of cockroaches I
think of the legs it's little and to
crawl across your livingroom floor so I
made the legs very prominent in my piece
so the
the legs down here it's got this long
abdomen right here and then we've got
the antenna right up here because that's
also a feature because they're they're
going like this all on the floor while
they're skittering across and it has
sort of like a cylindrical body yeah and
that's really what I mean common here
was the cylindrical body and the legs so
where's the penis ah yes sorry
right down here zero points yeah and me
with the conservative zero but heads
which is the Jeopardy stratagem oh
release the balloon hope you enjoyed
this balloon making challenge we
certainly had a lot of fun thank you
that everyone tweeted us so thank you to
everyone that tweeted us suggestions and
we hope to do this kind of challenge
again maybe not balloon making but more
crafty stuff in the future so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]